Bitcoin versus gold I personally will
always choose Bitcoin over gold because
we're moving into this new digital world
and so we need money which can simply
cater to that right now you can move
Bitcoin through space and time for as
little as 10 cents how are you going to
be moving billions of dollars worth of
gold from one part of the world to
another the world is so unpredictable
right now we don't know what's happening
whether it's inflation Wars lockdowns
whatever it is and so if you really want
to be that true sovereign individual and
have the ability to flee and run to go
to the best Safe Haven how are you going
to do that with your gold you're just
going to leave it sitting in the country
where you're running from you can't and
plus it's going to cost you a lot of
money if you do want to transfer that
gold plus if the government even allows
you to move that amount of gold out of
the country with Bitcoin you can flee
with the keys in your head it costs a
tiny little bit of money just to send
billions across the world through space
and time